Cuál fue el papel de la reina durante la
época colonial y qué pasará ahora con la
figura de la monarquía en los países que
tienen esta relación histórica con los
británicos
Bueno en realidad lo que hay que decir
es que la reina entra a su reinado y es
coronada en un contexto en el cual
Inglaterra está pasando de ser una
monarquía Imperial hacer otra cosa y la
reina pasa a ser de ser la cabeza una
monarquía Imperial a la cabeza una
comadre bien Es decir antes de que la
reina asuma India se independiza de la
corona británica y una vez que la Reina
Isabel ASUME en 1953 diferentes países
se van a ir independizando en ese
contexto y en ese sentido la reina logra
algo Bastante importante que es
refuncionalizar el lugar que tiene la
monarquía es decir darle un nuevo lugar
a esa monarquía en qué sentido Bueno si
bien la monarquía inglesa es una
monarquía que existe desde hace más de
10 siglos Y con toda la teología
política que la rodea tiene más de 10
siglos lo que lo que podríamos decir es
que en esos 10 siglos ha ido cambiando
la función muchísimo la función del
reino para no irme tan atrás uno podría
decir Bueno
desde el siglo desde la revolución
gloriosa en el siglo 17 El poder del Rey
se ha ido acotando cada vez más No ahí
va avanzando El poder del parlamento y
la figura del Rey se ha convertido en
una figura que no gobierna directamente
sino que reina en ese contexto de
refuncionalización del rol del monarca
en el siglo 19 una de las maneras que
tuvo El Monarca de tener un nuevo un
nuevo lugar Los Monarcas ingleses ha
sido en convertirse en las cabezas del
imperio en los jefes del estado de
aquellos de aquellos países que formaban
parte de de las colonias Bueno a Isabel
le tocó
refuncionalizar ese lugar es decir a
medida que esos países se fueron
independizando Isabel tuvo que que que
que que que permanecer o darle un lugar
a la corona diferente o en ese fue el
ser la jefa de estado en eso quiero
interrumpir la precisamente para
preguntarle sobre ese papel y esa
refuncionalización de la que usted nos
habla Cuál fue el papel de la Reina
Isabel al lograr un pacto voluntario y
no este mandato Imperial de gobierno
directo sobre la como Wells
específicamente sobre los 14 países que
la eligieron para hacer su jefe de
estado y qué pasa ahora que Carlos III
ASUME Bueno es un papel simbólico no el
que tiene el jefe de estado no es un
papel que sea político pero es un papel
que genera cierta identidad entre esos
países no y hay una identificación y eso
sí puede ser un tema que hay que ver qué
pasa no porque hay una identificación no
tanto con la monarquía en sí Sino lo que
dice muchos es que hay una
identificación con la figura de la reina
con la persona de la reina sobre todo
después de tantas décadas no entonces en
había una aceptación de la reina y había
incluso una una una una buena una buena
buena mirada en relación con la reina de
Gran desafío para Carlos es ver cómo se
Eh sí sí puede producir algún tipo de
refuncionalización
de esa figura o si la persona de Carlos
logra la adhesión que logró la figura de
la reina Hay que tener algo
Claro porque nosotros digo en la
repúblicas estamos acostumbrados a a
mirar capas con más más atención Cómo es
la persona que ocupa el cargo Bueno eso
es algo que se supone que las monarquías
es distinto o no pasa en qué sentido
la idea de la monarquía o la teología
que está atrás de la monarquía es que el
cargo está por encima de la persona el
cargo es algo la corona bien Es algo que
debería garantizarse o que debería tener
continuidad Más allá de las personas que
ocupen Esa esa Corona que estén debajo
de esa Corona entonces
uno podría ver si Carlos logra la misma
adhesión o no pero desde una perspectiva
teórico política uno podría decir bueno
la figura de la corona debería
permanecer Sí y la Reina de Isabel II
era la última líder que vivió la Segunda
Guerra Mundial qué implica su muerte
como símbolo del siglo 20
Bueno creo que es una de las creo que es
la última gran figura del siglo 20 que
que tuvo un lugar central en el siglo 20
que que quedaba no es decir y que
quedaba ejerciendo funciones la Reina
Isabel vivió la Segunda Guerra Mundial
no como reina no como princesa Pero
además va a vivir con textos muy
distintos Y eso Y eso es lo interesante
va a vivir el contexto de posguerra y la
Guerra Fría el surgimiento de un estado
de bienestar en Inglaterra la caída y la
crisis de ese estado de bienestar con el
surgimiento de de de un gobierno
neoliberal el fin de la Guerra el fin de
la Guerra Fría
el brexit digo va a vivir con texto muy
distintos y en todos esos contextos tan
distintos en los que ha vivido la la
figura de la corona se ha mantenido es
decir lo interesante de eso es que
tenemos contextos muy muy diferentes
signados por una por una increíble
continuidad y hay un secreto o algunos
historiadores dicen bueno Cuál es el
secreto para lograr esa continuidad Y
esa estabilidad que ha tenido la reina y
la monarquía en contextos políticos tan
distintos bueno y algunos dicen eso
silencio bien eh Eh Eh Eh la reina Ha
logrado
no Mostrar porque eso es lo que tiene
que hacer un rey políticamente
lo que piensa lo que creía Por supuesto
que tiene un rol político en el sentido
de que puede influenciarse reúne con los
primeros ministros pero pero el silencio
de Isabel es importantísimo para tratar
de entender Bueno cómo hizo para
mantenerse todo este tiempo en contextos
políticos tan tan distintos